OPPORTUNITY FOR NORTH KOREA, AND
IF THEY DON'T TAKE IT, THE
OPPORTUNITY WILL NEVER BE THERE
AGAIN.
IT RAISES THE STAKES BIG TIME.
>> Laura: THANK YOU.
AMERICA HAS STUNNING,
BREATHTAKING HISTORY OF
DIPLOMATIC FAILURE WHEN IT COMES
TO CURBING NORTH KOREA'S MISSILE
PROGRAM.
SINCE 1985, U.S. ADMINISTRATIONS
HAVE TRIED AND BAR GOES,
SANCTIONS, TREATIES,
APPEASEMENT.
NO COMBINATION OF STICKS AND
CARROTS HAS EVER WORKED.
WHY COULD IT BE DIFFERENT THIS
TIME?
LET'S GO BACK TO THE PANEL HERE
TO DISCUSS IT.
MIKE, YOU WANT TO ADDRESS A
POINT HOW THINGS GO BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS AND HOW WE TALK
ABOUT THEM AS MEMBERS OF THE
MEDIA.
I WANT YOU TO TOUCH IMAP BUT I
WANT YOU TO TOUCH ON THE ONE END
ON POINT THAT TRUMP MADE.
HE BASICALLY SAID YOU HAVE ONE
SHOT AT THIS.
AND THIS IS IT.
IS IT BLUSTER OR IS AT THE WAY
HE FEELS?
>> IT'S IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
MILITARY EXERCISES, MILITARY
THREATS LAST YEAR, THE EXTREME
SANCTIONS, PERHAPS OTHER THINGS.
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT YET.
THERE'S A KIND OF INTIMIDATION
OF CHAIRMAN KIM.
HE IS 34 YEARS OLD.
HE IS VERY POISED.
HE IS CALM, TOUCHING
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ARM THE WAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOUCHES HIS ARM.
ON THE SERVICE, THERE IS THIS
MILD CAMARADERIE.
AS A GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL, I LOOK
AT THIS IN TERMS OF THE MEDIA
OUTSIDE.
CHRIS WALLACE AND THE OTHERS,
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IS GOING
ON IN THAT ROOM.
FOR ALL WE KNOW THERE IS CLOSE
TO A WALK OUT AND BACK TO THE
TABLES AND EVEN MILITARY
THREATS.
OR IT'S THE OPPOSITE, THAT THEY
HAVE A SCHEDULE FOR DISMANTLING,
THEY HAVE SPECIFIC THINGS.
FIRST STOP THE PLUTONIUM
REPROCESSING.
THEN THE UNDERGROUND URANIUM
ENRICHMENT FACILITIES.
IN THE CASE OF NIXON AND MAO AND
LATER WITH GORBACHEV AND
REYKJAVIK.
THE DOCUMENTS WERE KEPT SECRET
FOR 30 YEARS.
SCHOLARS ONLY FOUND OUT, THIS
WAS THE DEAL.
IT'S NOT A PREMATURE COMMENTARY,
GOING OUT ON A LIMB, THESE
JOURNALISTS WHO THINK THEY KNOW
IT'S GOING ON.
THEY REALLY DON'T.
I HAVE A HUNCH WE'RE GOING TO
LEARN MORE AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
BUT ONLY AS WE BEGIN TO SEE WHEN
WE'LL BE THE FIRST
DISMANTLEMENT.
THERE HAVE BEEN TWO SMALL STEPS
ALREADY.
BLOWING UP OF THE TUNNELS WITH
THE PRESS NEARBY.
IT WASN'T A HOAX.
>> Laura: IT WAS ALREADY KIND
OF COLLAPSED?
>> THAT STRANGE STORY ABOUT THE